mesdames et messieurs les présidents de
la 37e cérémonie des césar
guillaume canet
[Musique]
les films nommés ce soir appartiennent
tous à des genres totalement différents
cette année est une année record dans
l'histoire du cinéma français et ceux à
l'ère du téléchargement ce qui prouve
bien que rien ne remplace le plaisir de
découvrir un film avec du public et
l'ambiance d'une salle de cinéma
je suis très fier de déclarer cette
37ème cérémonie des césars ouverte
bonjour bonjour je suis antoine de
caunes le maître de cérémonie
je vous présente le dr alban et la scène
euro dance des années 90 ma part c'est
pas vraiment le sujet regardez la ligne
bleue là c'est l'économie mondiale la
ligne rouge c'est le cinéma français
c'est pourquoi pour sauver l'économie
j'ai décidé d'aller faire un tour dans
les films qui ont fait exploser le box
office afin dé récupérer une partie du
pactole du cinéma français l'opération a
duré combien quand enfin le temps de la
cérémonie de ce soir le fond ça donne
l'impression que ça dure 9 heures mais
en fait on expédie 104 5 heures salle et
pour des remerciements
alors un conseil pour accélérer le
rythme de la cérémonie si vous montez
sur scène ce soir ne remerciez pas vos
parents
alors soyons honnêtes sur youn est s'il
vous avez véritablement élevé avec
attention s'il vous avez donné tout
l'amour que vous méritiez vraiment vous
ne sauriez pas dans le cinéma
le césar du meilleur premier film est
attribué 1
le cochon de gaza de sylvain estivale
c'est un grand honneur pour moi et pour
tous les cochons vietnamiens
voilà merci il est où le cochon il est
où le cochon cherche on cherche cherche
au cochon il est là les la nuit là ya eu
six mois plus bien là on vient ici kaïs
il ya au papa papa nous les roannais
sont tombés et bègue nous phoque pour
clio sur fox news
au moins alors que nous donne des bons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le césar du meilleur montage est
attribué à leur regard des ventes d'air
c'est la plus belle occasion pour moi
qui m'est donnée aujourd'hui maïwenn de
te remercier jeu je vis des aventures
cinématographiques avec toi incroyable
et ce césar je suis heureuse heureuse de
la voir aujourd'hui parce que c'est avec
toi ça fait neuf ans que tu m'a tendu la
main tu es ma petite fée je me dis
souvent que je t'aime trop mais moi je
te dis je ne t'ai murray jamais assez
maïwenn je te remercie
merci à vous mon swing leurs pattes
quand vous disiez non c'était pas une
blague quoi une blague
oui à tout non pour super drôle déjà
pino manquant je dis non c'est non voilà
l'exemple vous savez bien qu'il ya des
noms qui veulent dire oui oui mais là
c'est un nom qui veut dire non je ne
viens pas aux césar en armure
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
pardon messieurs pardon pardon pardon
voilà monsieur astier fait du cinéma
maintenant monsieur astier sur canal+
il ne fait plus des petits programmes
télé sur une chaîne gratuite
il fait du cinéma avec un grand c il
vient de faire un film avec isabelle
adjani
monsieur est ce qui fait du cinéma voilà
un propos ni en colère et costaud avec
ta bande de baltringues plus que jamais
vous voir gérard pourquoi tu me parles
toujours marrant comme ça non parce que
finalement c'est un peu comme si tu
disais exactement le contraire de ce que
tu penses il a peur de ce que tu ressens
pour moi bah là tu vois c'est safina
français que j'aime cinéma qui fait des
câlins
et quand gun moins chère kate qu'est
tiki tiki ti cats my sweet quête il
n'est jamais trop tard pour gagner à
césar is never to let twin césar
car kate les bas tout au finish causse
kate winslet
tu as travaillé dur pour y arriver il
sera doit fumer tue comme j'ai moi même
bien ramé pour clamer le fondement d'une
vague reconnaissance à msf
trois matchs de la fondation bingguo
commissionnement concluant ici les
clivages de génération inc ont plusieurs
le clivage est généreuse car au bout du
chemin il ya cette chose qui gagne aux
bulls
thomas et les jeunes aux chevilles
bree fortement et qu'on nomme le césar
brillante photographes comme on disait
que je te remets car tu l'a pas volé
fioutch et agrumes eddy kapend for your
eyes and today et de votre gentillesse
est de 7 charmant soirée
pour remettre le prochain césar
j'appelle mathieu kassovitz
[Musique]
mathieu je dois dire que je suis à la
fois ravi de vous voir et en même temps
une qui peut surprise le goût moment je
suis honoré ma province honoré attendons
attendez j'ai honoré votre promesse ben
oui c'est un homme d'honneur
j'ai appris le cinéma français et les
baisers qu'un fils de merde
merci bonsoir il est drôle il est tendre
il est émouvant c'est une boule
d'énergie et de bonne humeur kad merad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je l'aimé
et le césar de la meilleure actrice dans
un second rôle est attribué à
quand même fort dans les coins du
sénégal
moi je suis très fière d'être une
actrice espagnole
mais ce soir grâce à vous et grâce à lui
je je sens que je suis une petite partie
de la famille du cinéma français et ça
j'aime parce que je me sens très bien
chez vous merci vraiment merci à mater
bonsoir mes petits chatons des césar
vous vous demandez sans doute ce que je
fais ici en inde et bien à peu à la
manière de chatons jean dujardin qui a
su si bien vous savez faire campagne à
hollywood
moi je suis ici depuis à peu près dix
jours pour faire finalement quasiment la
même chose mais à bollywood
le
[Musique]
m
et le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à bérénice bejo dans un article
je dois vous avouer quelque chose je
voulais vraiment je le voulais je vous
ai tout adoré toutes les autres actrices
ils sont nominés mais je le voulais je
pensais pas je serais tellement ému mais
je n'arrive pas y croire
voilà je décide de continuer et de
mériter ce prix je vous remercie j'y
crois pas voilà merci beaucoup
en tout cas je suis fier d'être le
premier à remettre le césar du meilleur
français dans une actrice américaine et
jeu je remercie l'académie pour ça alors
les nommé pour le césar du meilleur
français dans une actrice américaine
son benjamin millepied dans natalie
portman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
olivier martinez dans ally berry
je crois qu'il ya un malentendu lasser
c'est une un calembour fine ces
plaisanteries de notre prendre ce
n'existe pas ce césar c'est même un goût
assez douteux si vous voulez mon avis
c'est obscène
oui c'est pour ça que j'étais un peu
embarrassé en faisant je vous comprends
je vous comprends encore le gagnant est
omar sy
je suis désolé j'ai parlé de mes parents
et de mes enfants et en garde mais j'en
veux dire [ __ ] j'en plusieurs [ __ ]
je voulais faire des vannes et tout mais
j'y arriverai pas merci à tous ces pros
voté pour moi et tous les autres qui ont
été nommés franchement je n'y croyais
pas vous êtes des grands les mecs et
juste à bord moment à côté du vôtre
c'était un kiff monumental donc je vais
partir monsieur staff
plus
cherry père comptait j'ai fait jour je
m'en fous mais je suis comme haddad
merci beaucoup merci à tous
ça c'est encore le voisin il se met tout
le temps là dont il est persuadé que
c'est son parking
gérard patriti je vais tuer un café j'ai
pas patrick jp garrett j'étais garé rue
de gt gt garage et au téléphone garer
avec gérard voilà alors ok omar m'a pas
tuée merci moi même dit si tu veux
récupérer ton portable tu sais si tu
restes à pair on s'use pas pour un
portable ça te ramener bien qu'on soit
ou pas marrant vous bon portable c'est
toute ma vie j'ai tous les numéros du
cinéma français dans mon portable et le
césar du meilleur film est attribué à
the artist c'est un film qui parle
vraiment de très très très très très bas
aux personnes voulaient au départ et
voilà on y est on est au plus haut donc
on et ça fait une très belle histoire
tout ça est vraiment tous les gens qui
ont participé au film on fait pour des
bonnes raisons et
et c'est en fait très émouvant et donc
donc merci merci thomas et je remercie
du coup claude berri parce que mon grand
père s'appelait roger langmann et qui
disait à son fils claude il faut donner
les cartes
merci à tous les gens qui ont collaboré
à ce film merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]